INMATES, INCLUDING THOSE INMATES
IN THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
KATY.
>> Katie: TRACE, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
JOINING US NOW WITH THE REACTION
IS THAT MAN CHALLENGING
GOVERNOR BROWN, CALIFORNIA
G.O.P. GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE
JOHN COX.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
TONIGHT.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU, KATIE, GREAT TO BE
WITH YOU.
THE ANARCHY IN CALIFORNIA?
IT SEEMS LIKE THINGS ARE FALLING
APART AT THE SEAMS.
THE GOVERNMENT IN SACRAMENTO IS
BEING PUSHED BACK ON COVER
RIGHTFULLY COME BY THESE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
HOW WILL YOU CHANGE THIS?
>> I APPLAUD ORANGE COUNTY, I
APPLAUD MY HOME COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO FOR STANDING UP TO
THIS.
THIS IS TYPICAL OF THE
POLITICIANS WHO ARE RUNNING THE
STATE INTO THE GROUND, KATIE.
THEIR FIRST JOB OUT TO ME TO
KEEP THE RESIDENTS OF THIS STATE
SAFE.
I'M GETTING INVOLVED, I'M
LEADING THE CHARGE, TO TALK TO
OTHER COUNTIES AS WELL AROUND
THE STATE ABOUT STANDING UP FOR
THIS.
THE VOTERS ELECT THEIR COUNTY
AND STATE OFFICIALS TO PROTECT
THEM.
THAT IS THE FIRST JOB OF
GOVERNMENT IS TO DO THAT.
AND THE IDEA THAT JERRY BROWN
PICKS EASTER WE    WEEKEND TO PR
PICKS EASTER WE    WEEKEND TO PO
PICKS EASTER WE    WEEKEND TO PN
PEOPLE WHO HAVE COMMITTED CRIMES
AND WHO WERE LET OUT OF JAIL
VERY RECENTLY, IT'S NOT LIKE
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO SERVED
THEIR TIME 30 YEARS AGO AND HAVE
BEEN UPSTANDING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY.
QUITE THE CONTRARY.
A LOT OF THESE CRIMES WERE
COMMITTED IN 2003, 2004, 2005,
AND THEY HAVE RECENTLY GOTTEN
OUT OF JAIL.
THEY ARE A THREAT TO THE
COMMUNITY AND THEY ARE ILLEGAL
ALIENS.
THE GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE
OUGHT TO ACT TO PROTECT THE
PEOPLE OF THE STAGE.
I'M A BUSINESSMAN, JUST LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I SOLVE PROBLEMS.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS TRYING
TO SOLVE PROBLEMS AND KEEPING
THIS.
>> Katie: SOLVING THE PROBLEM,
YOU TALK ABOUT SPEAKING TO THESE
VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA, BUT
CLEARLY THEY ARE ELECTING PEOPLE
WHO BELIEVE IN THESE SANCTUARY
CITY POLICIES.
WHEN YOU ARE TRAVELING AROUND TO
CERTAIN PARTS OF CALIFORNIA,
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING DIRECTLY
FROM PEOPLE ON THE GROUND THERE?
WHAT ARE THEY SAYING TO YOU
ABOUT THESE SANCTUARY LAWS?
POLLING SHOWS THAT CALIFORNIANS
DON'T WANT TO BE A SANCTUARY
STATE, HOWEVER, THESE
POLITICIANS KEEP GETTING
REELECTED IN THESE BLUE COUNTIES
TO PASS LAWS THAT MAKE IT EASY
FOR CRIMINALS AND VIOLENT PEOPLE
TO GET AWAY FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
>> THE PEOPLE ARE RISING UP.
I APPLAUD THE MAYOR OF ESCONDIDO
I APPLAUD THE MAYOR OF ESCONDID
ESCONDIDO, A FRIEND OF MINE.
THE PEOPLE ARE MAKING THEIR
VOICES KNOWN TO THIS, KATIE.
THEY ARE CONCERNED.
LOOK AT WHAT KATE STEINLE'S
PARENTS WENT THROUGH.
THERE IS A YOUNG WOMAN IN
SONOMA COUNTY WHO IS DEAD
BECAUSE THE SHERIFF THEIR
INCIDENT INFORM I.C.E. WHEN THEY
RELEASED A DANGEROUS PERSON OUT
INTO THE POPULATION.
THIS CAN'T HAPPEN.
PEOPLE IN MY STATE HAVE BEEN
BEATEN DOWN BY THE MAJORITY
PARTY IN THE STATE.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST POVERTY
RATE, WE HAVE MORE PEOPLE ON
WELFARE THAN ANY OTHER STATE IN
THE COUNTRY.
OUR BUSINESS CLIMATE IS
HORRENDOUS.
OUR QUALITY OF LIFE IS
SUFFERING, KATIE.
WE ARE 50TH OUT OF 50, FOR
CRYING OUT LOUD!
I THINK THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
RISE UP AND CONTINUE THIS
BACKLASH ALL THE WAY THROUGH
NOVEMBER.
THEY WANT BETTER MANAGEMENT.
THEY ARE GOING TO GET IT.
I'M GOING TO CHANGE THE STATES.
>> Katie: IF YOU WOULD NOT,
WHICH WOULD BE NICE FOR
REPUBLICAN TEA WIN IN THAT
STAGE, GIVEN A TRACK RECORD OF
DEMOCRATS THE LAST COUPLE OF
DECADES, WHAT EXACTLY ARE YOU
PLANNING TO DO TO WORK WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO REVERSE
THIS TREND OF CRIMINAL ALIENS
OPERATING IN CALIFORNIA?